the way I figure it everyone gets a
miracle and we begin with a random
voiceover that sounds more like you
invited an annoying friend who decided
to start talking just as the movie
started why is this family just now
pulling up and the movers have already
unloaded half their stuff is it typical
for Reuters to just start moving someone
into a house without the homeowners
being there this may not be a sin I may
not be rich enough to understand how
hiring movers works this kid is just
really focused on dribbling practice
which is fair clearly he's terrible at
it of all the houses and all the
subdivisions in all the state of Florida
so it's like Casablanca only pathetic
Margo Roth Spiegelman this character's
name perfectly sums up this movie a
desperate over-the-top attempt to be
adorable that's a good way to make
friends quittin awkwardly and somewhat
angrily stare at the new neighbor girl
you can tell her parents don't love her
because she's not wearing a helmet or
you could read this like he's a dork
either way works there's a dead body
holding a gun that no one in this
neighborhood noticed everyone in this
neighborhood is either super lazy
collectively plotted to kill this man
and staged it as a suicide or just
extremely non-observant did this guy
shoot himself in the chest who shoots
themselves in the chest since this is
supposed to be a cute movie I guess it
would be kind of graphic for them to
find a guy with the back of his head
blown out you close your eyes when you
died and the rest of this movie does not
Chronicle her life as a serial killer
following the great tradition of
childhood friends and fiction no one
ever uses a door the kids always come in
through a window his wife works at
SeaWorld I bet there's a clue someone
needs to fill in Poirot jr. on the fact
that you don't really need clues to
solve a suicide it's almost 11:00 there
are plenty of objections as to why they
shouldn't look into this that come to
mind before SeaWorld is closed all the
strings inside him broke this is
something that sounds profound but means
absolutely nothing what is she trying to
prove by looking into this her strings
breaking comment seems like she has a
purpose but I am no closer to knowing
what her motivation is Margo always
loved mysteries maybe she loved him so
much
she became one they're desperately
trying to set up in a lure around this
child who was simply entitled and a
meddler and that concludes one of the
most pointless cold opens to a movie
I've ever seen if you haven't seen this
movie first of all don't but second of
all we don't hear about the guy who
killed himself in the neighborhood ever
again no one has ever taught this kid
how to brush teeth he's not using
toothpaste he's just sticking it in the
back of his mouth that he's walking
around his bedroom like it's a place
where you brush teeth
but does he think that's Margaret the
door he saw her walk out of his view
maybe one second before the doorbell
rang maybe she is such a mystery she has
the ability to alter the properties of
space-time if Margot is this brooding
mysterious loner type why is she so
popular and hanging out with all the
preppy cool kids maybe that's a part of
the mystery Margo was special by special
you mean Tom like the time she spent
three weeks traveling with the circus
Margo obviously has no parents if she
can just run off to the circus at 12 and
can tour with some band I've never heard
of only to reject the bassist who was
inexplicably within earshot of the
bouncer at the backstage door
I'm just insulted by this clue so her
soup would have to already be cooked and
sitting on the table with no one around
had the correct number of eyes SNPs and
she would have had to get them all in
order and they would have had to stay in
order before her sister got back to eat
it who clearly didn't notice it until
she went to eat it the biggest thing is
this is not a clue this is just her
telling her sister where she's going she
probably should have just written it on
a sticky note put that on a bowl or
anyone else she deemed worthy I was
never one of those people why would you
be you're the weird helmet wearing
neighbor boy it was afraid to look at a
dead body
Margo surpassed you before she was 13
she doesn't even tell her ghost parent
she's apparently run away to Mississippi
but she's gonna tell you I bet I made up
a radar are these teens big mass fans
it's the 21st century shouldn't this
cliche nor dick name be something like
torrent or JPEG now I feed a grape stick
of the pears tree like a princess she is
that wrong it's weird it's always beard
his persistence about wanting to Bank
use mom is high enough for it to be
strange that cue was not more annoyed by
it radars parents are trying to get into
the Guinness Book of World Records for
the largest collection of black Santa's
in one house notice he said trying is
there another family with a house filled
with black Santa's I think that's the
sadder story here but they have not yet
succeeded in having the most black
Santa's I need to borrow your car I
can't use your car oh boy this week
wound and boner swore for the same girl
since he was a little kid would not have
immediately turned this girl down nine
columns and your boyfriend's mom someone
has been reading jay-z's throwaway song
ideas journal he agrees to go and commit
several actual crimes with the girl who
has basically adored him for nine years
you can make mundane acts like pulling a
car out of a driveway way more epic and
life-changing if you throw some
electronic music under it and it gives
parents not hearing him feel out in
their Honda Odyssey in the middle of the
night and after Margo's parents were
loudly screaming her name Hobson they
are not telling me what sleeping pills
Q's parents are taking we are writing
wrongs and after that we're going to
wrong some rights pretentious teenagers
are terrible don't get me wrong but not
even the most vegan of the beret Brigade
would utter a sentence so trite this is
gonna be the best night of your life
Margaret was selfish meddling and now we
can add cocky she's really shaping up to
be a really lovable character pull in
here she had to tell him where to go
even though she told him where they were
going like five seconds earlier I like
I'm going to Duke in the fall and go to
med school become an oncologist
now obviously get married in that kids
by like 30 and then you'll be happy I
mean yeah probably that sounds like a
pretty good life habit College was fun
too I'm pretty sure those don't just
work right off the shelf I'm a big
believer in random capitalization she
would be very popular on AOL Instant
Messenger in the early 2000s this flota
subdivision is close to a big box store
that sells individually packaged whole
catfish still weird that's an awfully
judgmental cashier if they weren't said
to hurry I probably would have sent them
for not asking for the manager hey I'll
do it anyway Martha this is a bad idea
if you didn't have any wherewithal to
know this was a bad idea when Margo
crawled into his room in the middle of
the night we bring the rain down on her
enemies are we sure Margo didn't kill
that man from the beginning of the movie
did he really get that far away from his
clothes and not quickly grab some pants
at least he conveniently stops covering
his tiny dick just in time for Q to snap
a picture of his tiny dick also
congratulations our heroes have now
lightheartedly engaged in the deplorable
act of revenge porn the Rhode Island of
penises wasn't really the best thing
that presumably a team of writers could
come up with maybe the director just
told the model slash actress playing
Margo just to wing it the fact that she
put a large fish just out in her
backpack is also a prank on her now her
backpack and all its contents probably
reeked of fish does she think she's a
room at least that wasn't his real name
it's like she wants to make super sure
everyone knows she did all this and
leave behind enough evidence for her
parents to press charges which none of
them do how long does it take these
grown-ass adults to come downstairs this
house must be massive and contain large
sprawling staircases for them to have
enough time to get back outside we bring
the rain not
scattered showers how many I roll
moments am I gonna have when Margo says
something did she have that one in her
pocket for a while they're doing a lot
of standing around for two people trying
to be inconspicuous apparently none of
these large houses in this upscale
development have security systems
incredibly lucky they were able to pick
the lock without an alarm going off
casually walk upstairs with no one
seeing or hearing them and now they're
just standing on the foot of this guy's
bed like they've got all the time in the
world
she's such a free spirit and a rebel
even at a young age but she's still
listened to and complied with what this
guy told her to do in the 6th grade
this is not the right place for this pep
talk this is a movie based on a book
written by a man directed by a man with
a screenplay written by two men and it's
pretty obvious that none of them are
aware that in fact Nair burns your skin
like hell
weird natures I guess you can claim to
be a ninja and everyone you're missing
with is taking the same high-quality
brand of sleeping pills needlessly
sliding across the hood of a car in case
you forgot she was supposed to be a
badass come to Orlando
it looks like everywhere else you two
can feel winsome freedom by sticking
your head out of the window like a dog I
can't get arrested tonight or ever Q
doesn't understand that all these things
he did tonight could get him arrested
later soothing sounds of Corporate
America they have random Muzak playing
in this conference room which not only
would it not be playing in the middle of
the night it definitely would be playing
in a conference room the people telling
the story couldn't have picked a city
with a better skyline correction a
skyline queenly clear because if someone
doesn't catch you in the act of
committing a crime or shortly after you
can't be charged for that crime wait
that's not right
ah the old reflection signifies
duplicity trick it's a paper town roll
credits
I've lived here 11 years and I've never
come across anyone that cares about
anything that matters no one in the
whole city of Orlando you spent most of
that time either in high school or in
your subdivision but I promise there are
people in Orlando running soup kitchens
and this is her way of saying goodbye
when she could have just actually said
goodbye and we could have avoided the
rest of what happens in the movie which
is more of an inconvenience for the
character and also me let's just brother
proves that she's an asshole son Jimmy
wants to be happy why even do this why
introduce for one split second a
fake-out it was all a dream scenario she
must have set the picture this guy's
tiny dick as his locked screen
background that's the only explanation
for being able to show him that photo
that quickly every person he's walking
by is running into it is everyone moping
around this school not paying attention
to their surroundings coz Margo is
missing so this town does have law
enforcement I'm guessing he's here to
arrest key
for trespassing breaking-and-entering
and vandalism not your top candidates
for parents of the Year character in the
movie casually mentions in voiceover how
dear parents are when the three week
Margo spent at the circus was more than
enough information I'm like yeah what's
up let's do it's bad enough that we have
to listen to this sub Anthony Michael
Hall wax poetic about imaginary sex does
he have to try and talk like this too
there's something in Margo's window it's
a refrigerator a mug author Dan Brown
Michelangelo's David oh no wait it's
obviously a picture every um ever made
except Woody Guthrie that's a bold
statement to make when he's only looked
through a small portion of her records
this is a perfect example of Margo's
trite white teenaged ass using a photo
of Woody Guthrie to lead someone to
Wilco if you think her favorite bits of
leaves of grass or self-involved weak
until you see her annotated version of
Atlas Shrugged
well Whitman's from New York Woody
Guthrie lived in New York for a while
that's something she's in New York two
famous people lived in New York somehow
he rightly interprets that as a clue he
just happens to look over at the hinges
on his door and sees a little piece of
paper that just happened to stay there
for several days we have school I don't
show up is this a moment of growth for Q
seems more like this girl is dragging
him down to her selfish level of apathy
it was a little too easy for Q to
convince his friends who also never do
anything wrong to skip class well time
to wash ah
hey I can't tell if that voice is Sean
Connery or Tom Brokaw Jimmy Stewart last
time I was this carrot I said my mom's
fat Qi were you out get that scared
every single night you should know
better than to set him up like that
maybe he also secretly thinks his mom is
hot and hearing Ben say things like this
is the only way for Q to express his
true feelings
well it's mono what if it's literally
anything else this statement includes
more things that are less threatening ie
woodland critters or a tumbleweed so
it's not a valid argument for why they
should leave I'm starting to think these
three characters are the only ones who
are in band I also think that there's no
band director because no teacher has
been curious as to why three students
hang out in the band room after school
every day if they're all tuba they're
it's not a party or maybe it's the
craziest party you've ever been to in
your life we know that this is a dream
because Margo would never wear a dress
like that it might not be a dream
because she probably would wear a hoodie
over it hey how soon can you dare no one
can speak at a normal volume on the
phone at parties clubs etc get it
together Hollywood party at unreasonably
giant mansion owned by the dick popular
kid whose parents are never home cliche
lacy waited until that moment to get
startled and say who's there also she
didn't lock the door in the first place
what's up are you doing what he was
doing is more normal than what lacy is
do and then she stood on the couch and
shushed the entire party and told them I
have chlamydia Laci clearly has problems
with association she was upset that
people only see her as a pretty face but
she ended up in the hot tub because her
friend told everyone she has chlamydia
which doesn't have anything to do with
how this conversation started more
convenient clues in unlikely places that
cue just happens to be in pages ripped
out of the book that way so we know
there was a page there that was ripped
out why are they so scared of this hole
still does radar have mild amnesia they
know what is through the hole they put
there the other day they are giving it
their all and trying to set these two up
to like each other but I don't believe
it for a second if this is supposed to
be some version of Wikipedia Margo is
quirky no wouldn't be there long enough
for anyone to find it unless she has
impeccable timing
nobody gonna stop no we're not stopping
bro don't mmm just think about something
else rather than try to distract him you
can also pull over for literally two
minutes to let him beat longest
urination scene in teen movie history if
he's still drunk there's no way he
wouldn't get piss all over that car I'm
the greatest that shook up the world
conveniently timed pothole why are we a
mission impossible in this trip to the
gas station he said they had six minutes
if they are running around like they're
already out of time are they all gonna
get back in the car with four and a half
minutes to spare remember that other
movie based on the book written by that
same guy everyone liked better than this
one well here's a guy from that movie
even though there is a serious time
crunch let's all have keep looking
around moments and then snap back into
action mom I'm sorry it was super last
minute that was one of the few moments
where an adult showed the slightest bit
of concern in this movie without that
the moment with the teacher and earlier
with the detective I would be pretty
sure this movie is a live-action
adaptation of Ed Edd and Eddy Cue is a
chronic issue with not looking at the
road for very long periods of time when
he's driving were three quarters of the
way into the movie and this is the first
time where that has become a problem
cube clearly ate his head and we see
later that he is bleeding but here we
see Q looking exactly the same as he did
before she can be a couple hours all
right
Raiders timetable has really seen the
delay at this point he is not freaking
out about it like he was at the gas
station maybe a near-death experience
has taught him that prom really isn't
that being important what was it you
wanted to tell me back at Jase's house
before you puked yourself what almost
made her throw up she now finds
endearing she asked me someone like
Alana doesn't really deserve you only a
nerd can swoop along and tell the pretty
and popular girl that only a man like
him can deserve her
if she's a literal prize to be won your
million made me save you the black Santa
thing isn't that funny it's mostly dumb
and would worry me if I was his
significant other that the dumbness is
genetic I tell them
so radar gauge for telling his buddies
but it's clear the two girls gossiped
about it enough to set up a wager so
what do they think she's just gonna be
waiting in this shed for probably days
and now they're just gonna look around
in the open field for a girl who isn't
dead no one suggested that they go to an
actual nearby town because it would be
ridiculous to just wait for her to show
up here like she would miraculously know
that her friends got all her clues and
made this 22 hour drive he should get
that nose twitch checked out and just as
dumb luck would have it Margo just
happens to walk by the bus station right
as Q is able to see her walk by yeah I
always think lose so you know I was fine
that is not why people intentionally
leave clues that's like having a
scavenger hunt being surprised if people
find what they're hunting I'm sure that
most teenage runaways assume they'll be
fine before they disappear if she really
wanted him to know she was fine she
should have said to him right after the
night of criminal activity I'm running
away but I'll be fine and then I
wouldn't had to watch this movie I'm
just as selfish as she is I have no idea
who I am why do you think I'm here up
until that last thing she was making
sense but I have to say there are plenty
of people that don't know who they are
and still don't selfishly abandon their
friends and family to figure out who
they are the myth of Margo Roth
Spiegelman if I hear someone say her
full name again I'm gonna start assuming
that in the grand tradition of John
Wilkes Booth and Lee Harvey Oswald she
assassinated a president a paper town
for a paper girl annoyingly thin
metaphor aside she's not even in the
paper town the paper town is aglow which
is where key win they are now in Roscoe
New York an actual town you were my
first partner in crime I wanted you to
be my last let's add user' to the big
board of negative margo attributes
everybody else's ten things for the last
time but I was doing them first is this
movie an annotation of Q's college essay
and even though Margo totally
manipulated cue and was generally kind
of jerky to him they still shared this
passionate kiss you could come with me
you know you can't imagine how many
times
it says words but in this moment of
clarity Q realized that he doesn't want
to be homeless also I was able to make
it back in time to make it to prom I'm
supposed to believe that he was able to
leave upstate New York and go on a
twenty two hour bus ride and prom would
still be happening or do they have a
weird problem that starts at 6:30 a.m.
the next day someone else said she's on
the west coast teaching surf lessons in
Malibu and I say she's panhandling in a
rural town in upstate New York
so the Lord this forest is old very old
darling it's a big thing
ee Tommy Tommy Tommy Tommy you always
say that the same thing every time I
through never again too dangerous that's
why I say I'm always right - would you
forget about it in a day or two yeah
well days me forgetting or over I think
me remembering just begun would you look
at this fucking town man it's dead
imagine how many people out there right
now a fucking man my head just going in
what do you say we get out of here and I
go put a baby in you oh hey guys what
what there's something in Margo's window
has that thing always been there I don't
know the shades never drawn